The countdown to Eleven and the gang's big
showdown with Vecna and the Mind Flayer has
begun.
And it looks like the Upside Down's villains
could well win the next battle,
It is over Eleven.
You have freed me.
You can't stop this now.
with El's failure to beat the big bad foreshadowed
when Dustin rolled an 11 and failed to beat
Vecna in his D&D game at the start of Season
4.
That's a miss!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining all the clues to
why Eleven and co will need to use time travel
to eventually defeat the show's villains.
Spoilers and speculation ahead, so take care.
The idea of time travel in Stranger Things
was heavily hinted towards the end of Season
3, when Dustin, Erica, Steve and Robin stumbled
into a screening of Back To The Future.
Einstein has just become the world's first
time traveler!
And right off the bat in Season 4, in Eleven's
opening scene she says this:
Today is Day 185.
Feels more like ten years.
Joyce says time is funny like that.
Emotions can make it speed up or slow down.
We are all time travellers if you think about
it.
The idea that happy or sad feelings can affect
the way we perceive time is analogous to how
Eleven draws on joyful memories, like her
mother's love, to take down One in their first
confrontation, versus how Vecna exploits his
victim's feelings of guilt and sorrow to trap
them, then kill them.
And there are clues right from the pilot episode,
through seasons two and three, then four,
that time and its representation through clock
motifs will be crucial to understanding and
defeating the villains of the Upside Down.
For starters, we know that One hated the way
humans use time to impose their own sense
of order on the world, something we see during
his villain's monologue while a young Henry
Creel stares at the Creel House grandfather
clock
Seconds, minutes, hours, days, weeks, months,
years, decades.
Each life a faded, lesser copy of the one
before.
The way he reverses the hands on the grandfather
clock, not only points to his disdain for
the norms of how time usually works, but it's
also a little clue to time reversal and travel
in the show.
And given the Alice in Wonderland reference
via his sister's name,
It looks like a fairy tale.
when the young Henry kills a rabbit, it's
not surprising as it's like he's killing the
character who was obsessed with time in the
Lewis Carroll story.
It's also curious how all the way back in
the first season, when Eleven makes her first
contact with the Demogorgon, the event that
rips open a gate to the Upside Down in Hawkins,
there's the sound of a clock ticking while
she's in the Void, hinting at Vecna's presence
in the background.
There's also a chiming sound effect in Season
1's first episode after Will sees the Demogorgon
and falls off his bike.
Then at the very end of Season 2 episode 4,
after Hopper goes into the Mind Flayer's tunnels,
you can hear the sound of a clock ringing.
And in the third season, just after the Mind
Flayer possesses Billy and he gets pulled
into the Upside Down, there's the sound of
clocks chiming in the background.
What do you want?
And after Billy comes out of that vision,
you can also hear a gong as he staggers around
suffering from being in the heat and the sun.
The Hawkins clocktower also appears in the
first shot of the Horror in the Heartland
news report in Season 3, which is also another
Back To The Future easter egg given the importance
of the clocktower to time travel in that movie.
And thanks to two of our amazing movie lovers,
Rebecca Strain and Arianna, for noticing that
Max's counsellor Ms Kelly wears a clock necklace,
which I think also looks rather like a key,
a possible hint that time will be the answer
to how the gang eventually defeat Vecna.
Another possibility for this detail is that
it's a hint that Ms Kelly is being used in
some way by Vecna or the Mind Flayer, similar
to how Will and Billy were spies for the villain.
After all, Max discovered the therapist had
been helping Chrissy and Fred, both of whom
end up as Vecna's victims.
Fred was seeing Ms. Kelley too.
Another clock-related detail that another
of our awesome movie lovers Chris Vellner
pointed out is how Black Widow spiders often
have hour glass markings on their abdomen,
something you can see when a young Henry Creel
is drawing one, a lethal clue also to how
once Vecna ensnares you, the countdown begins
to your death.
There's also a deep-cut time-related connection
between One and Watchmen, as the same musical
theme plays when One reveals his origin story
as also plays during the birth of Dr Manhattan.
Like Stranger Things, Watchmen heavily features
clock motifs, and Dr Manhattan also has the
ability to experience time in a non-linear
way.
Both the awakening of Henry Creel's powers
and Dr Manhattan's birth take place in 1959,
and on top of that the main events of Season
4 take place in 1986, the same year that the
Watchmen comics were first published.
And the way Eleven evaporates One into dust,
sending him into the Upside Down where he
becomes Vecna, has parallels with the way
Jon Osterman is evaporated by accident during
a radioactive particle test and disappears
before becoming Dr Manhattan.
Now, a character a lot of you have been asking
about is Eight, aka Kali, Eleven's lost sister
who she met back in Season 2.
She's mentioned in Season 4 by One when he's
talking to Eleven:
Do you remember the day a strange woman came
to see you?
This would've been when Eight was still here.
It seems pretty clear then that Eight used
her powers to cast illusions to escape the
lab before One went on his rampage and killed
the other test subjects.
And I think she'll be back before everything
is over to help Eleven take down Vecna and
the Mind Flayer.
Or, given her hatred of Brenner and the Hawkins
lab, it's possible she could ally with One
instead.
In fact, there was some foreshadowing of her
return in the crossword that Brenner completes
in the opening scene.
One of the clues is for the "Wife of Shiva",
the answer to which is Kali.
In the Hindu tradition, Kali is the Goddess
of Time, Change and Death, and perhaps together
with Eleven, they will find a way to reverse
an event in time.
Also next to the crossword in that newspaper
is another clock-related easter egg with an
ad for a jewellers and watchmakers who offer
"watch repairing" services.
Now, if any of these clues seem too coincidental,
it's worth remembering that the Duffer Brothers
have said that right from the very beginning
of the series, they wrote a 25-page document
which outlined all the mythology for the show
and the Upside Down and how it worked.
Plus, the show's set decorator has said that
'every item, every tiny piece of set dressing,
is intentional.'
So, Dustin's Sherlock Holmes quote...
The world is full of obvious things which
nobody by any chance ever observes.
... is basically telling us that the clues
and answers to the mysteries behind Stranger
Things are all laid out in little details
in the show.
On top of that, before it was renamed Stranger
Things, the original title for the show was
Montauk.
Montauk is the name of a real-life place on
Long Island which has inspired numerous conspiracy
theories about experiments carried out at
the military base there.
According to Wikipedia, a book called "The
Montauk Project: Experiments in Time" claims
experiments at the government facility opened
"a porthole in time" that "allowed […] travel
[to] anywhere in time or space" via a "time
tunnel".
The book also describes the time an alien
monster travelled through the tunnel, causing
damage and killing numerous people before
it was killed.
A lot of evidence then points to time travel
playing some crucial part in Stranger Things
before the final season is over, and the Duffer
Brothers have said that the first part of
Season 4 is the beginning of the end, so to
quote the Time-manipulating wizard Doctor
Strange,
We're in the Endgame now.
I think it's possible that Season 4 will end
on a cliffhanger, perhaps a tragedy affecting
one of the main characters that will need
some kind of time travel to fix.
This could be similar to Avengers: Infinity
War where the heroes lose, and many of them
seemingly die, only to eventually return in
Endgame when the Avengers use time travel
to fix things.
The most extreme outcome could be that all
the show's events are undone so that Eleven
is never taken from her mother and lives a
normal, happy life.
I don't think wiping out the entire story
would be especially popular though, so let's
hope whatever is planned is something more
interesting than that.
Funnily enough, there was a Rick and Morty
easter egg in Season 4, via the name Rick
Sanchez which appears on the list of Ricks
that the gang searches for at the video store.
Interestingly, Rick and Morty, a show which
features multiple alternate universes, initially
had a no-time-travel rule until it introduced
a whole episode to show why time travel was
such a bad idea.
Of course, Stranger Things is always loaded
with incredible details, such as the hidden
sound effect that reveals how as a child Henry
Creel might have got his powers from the Upside
Down, which I explain in my Season 4 easter
eggs video.
Tap here to watch that or follow the link
in the video description.
So, movie lovers, how do you think time travel
will end up being used in Stranger Things?
Or do you think there's another way to defeat
Vecna and the Mind Flayer?
Let me know in the comments below.
Next, tap here for my full breakdown of the
ending of Volume 1 and what else to expect
in the big Part 2 finale.
And if you liked this video, do leave a thumbs-up,
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for enjoying Stranger Things with me
and hope you have a marvellous movie-loving
week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!